well I'm joined Now by The Royal
biographer Tom Bauer journalist limb
Barber and author historian Dr Tessa
Dunham well welcome to my panel this is
probably the a the most erudite and
secondly the most opinionated panel I've
probably ever amassed in the history of
his great country which is fitting from
what we're about to debate tomorrow tom
is the only correlation any of us has
seen I was in 1953 I was just good
enough
I've seen you both up to see you would
jump in or a youngster of the younger
generation Tom
I know that so do you have any memories
though oh absolutely you do what do you
remember about the first uh cramped
around the tiny screen 20 people all
trying to appear at a black and white
image because TV had just come off just
come on and we found someone who had a
TV and it was terribly exciting we
learned about it and then you're the
same I remember I most exciting moment
was when the pairs progresses actually
put the crowns on or what whatever
they're called Coronas and you saw this
wonderful flash of white arms from
nowhere it's like the ballet it was a
certain magic I think probably because
television was black and white which I
think makes everything look classier but
obviously because also Tessa because
Queen Elizabeth was 26 years old and
beautiful yeah and it was almost like
this ex you know it's like a Hollywood
event of this beautiful young Starlet
but you know exceeding after the tragedy
of her father dying Charles doesn't have
the benefit of any of that he has
multi-color he has social media he has
aged not on his side it's a it's a tough
challenge for him well it's really
interesting I've spoken with a lot of
veterans who remember that I feel
fatally ridiculous I just wanted to try
I'm also going to mention what you're
doing well in a tiara and I feel
ridiculous how do they carry it off I
don't know but anyway back to the matter
I had I speak to a lot of veterans and
they remember that day and they recall
feeling compassion towards Elizabeth the
unimpeachable the blemish free young
woman of vulnerability they went home
and prayed for her that night but
bizarrely I actually think tomorrow
because of his age because of his
checkered past because of where we're at
as a nation and our relationship with
the crown I think Charles is a hundred
times the more vulnerable than his
mother was 70 years well I think that's
right and Tom you know you've you've
monitored the Royals now very
assiduously for quite some time it does
feel like a pivotal moment in the
potential future of this monarchy well
it does and the question really is
whether a child can actually build a
rain which is separate obviously to his
mothers but actually improves impresses
the country and the people and bills uh
following for the royal family and
monarchy and that is a huge challenge
for him the poll the polls the most
recent polls show that there's a lot of
support here for Charles not quite so
strong in other parts of the
Commonwealth and I interviewed the Prime
Minister of Australia there this week
who is a Republican and made it pretty
clear you know they want the end of a
British royal as the head of state but
they've always said that for years and
have managed to produce an alternative
well Charles actually is not that
popular he's only 54 in the mail poll
and monarchy is about most politicians
would take that well yes I know but I
mean the queen had over 70 yeah but she
was look let's be honest the queen Lynn
was a unique public figure I think in
modern history it's hard to think of
anyone with her I think profound Global
respect yeah really and a sort of
untarnished Reign in many ways I mean to
follow that is almost impossible
but I mean in theory I want us to be a
republic but it isn't going to happen is
it I mean because how would it happen
why would you want us to be a republic
well I think it's bad to be called
subjects I don't want to wear subject I
don't want to we've had we've had to
call Boris Johnson the right honorable
gentleman I mean we do use titles for
elected officials which make my skin
crawl okay but yeah just the sort of
bowing and scraping in general
here's the but I think the reason for
the monarchy the reason I love the idea
of it and the fact that we have this
royal family is it's almost unique now
in the world there are other monarchies
they're not as famous as ours and nobody
does Pomp pageantry and ceremony like
the Brits and I all my American friends
they'll all be tuning in tomorrow
because they love Tessa they love the
carriages the coaches they love the
military possession and this one by the
way this is staggering statistic so the
procession tomorrow is going to be twice
as big as the procession for the Queen's
funeral and three times the size of the
procession for the Platinum Jubilee both
of which felt enormous the truth is
where paper and over our insecurities
I'm sorry I have a properly FaceTime
this man I don't always agree with that
we'll end up having a book with this on
your head
um the truth is historically we didn't
do Pomp and pageant tribute bother with
it for victorious coronation for William
the force coronation when Britannia did
controversially an unchallenged ruler
waves when we start getting insecure in
the late 19th century the early 20th
century that's when we must a lot we
re-front Buck pal we make the mile wider
we get all the music Elder tralala and
then we go for Paris
actually actually no because actually
the last coronation came just a few
years after Little Britain stood up to
Nazi Germany and saved this country and
its freedoms and I think the Pomp
pageantry and ceremony of our great
military processions actually emanated
from the fact that yes when it actually
came to it Little Britain stood up and
punched okay big bad Hitler in the face
and save this country I don't agree with
you you can both have 70 years ago I'll
give you that as a buy but I would argue
that today we don't need I'm gonna go
with it because it'll look tragic if we
always went droop tomorrow and we'd got
everyone out in the horses and there was
no one there but I actually think it's
unnecessary we've had this glut of Royal
events we've all done very well fed off
the carcass of Pomp and ceremony but I
actually wonder how will this be viewed
by history do you think this will be our
last coronation Tom no I don't at all I
think that might be desperate needs the
monarchy and I think the monarchy is
very important for the country yeah but
the question really is today Tom when
you when you defend the monarchy what
what what do you give us the best
justification for it the alternative is
far worse right yeah it would be
president Blair or presidential or
president Boris Johnson but also you
know when uh prison or the king or
whoever goes to visit a hospital or
hospice or School Factory the people
they're really welcomed yes as
individuals who are sincerely interested
in their work and their problems and all
the confrontations they have which a
politician will they be interested for
their own vote so I think there's the
whole charitable side is brilliant on
the monarchy I think Charles is a very
Lord character I think he comes to the
throne with enormous amount of baggage
but tomorrow is the day actually having
written a book which is color skating
about him well he's got to put that to a
side one's got to think he now
represents an institution the fate of
the monarchy and for King William in the
future also in the animals that is very
important right and then the annals of
King history he's not that bad we've had
some Shockers um let me ask you the
unmentionables the Montecito Rebels
Harry and Megan yes what do you make of
them should we make anything more of
them should we just forget about that I
I feel well increase increasingly forget
about them I mean I think they're
they've peaked as it were and I think
the King was quite right to invite them
I mean it would look really awful at the
end do we believe that Meghan Markle
isn't coming because her sons four that
day well
I mean I've heard some Whoppers in my
time from her but nothing quite as
ridiculous as that the idea she would
give up being at Center Stage the
coronation for that is laughing it
doesn't well that actually was if he
wasn't going to be sent to Stage that's
why I think that may be why she isn't
coming yeah why do you think she's not
examine I think because she knows that I
mean look the latest polls show that
their popularity is yeah an all-time low
yeah the write down with prince Andrew
and there's a very good likelihood that
the British public will boo her pretty
loudly but the truth is whether she
should be there or shouldn't be there or
whatever's kept her away the Optics
with her and on us I don't agree and on
us being platform for the world tomorrow
the eyes are honest I don't understand
given the soft power that Charles has as
king head of 14 other Arms Why are all
the composers of the new music British
why are all the page boys white in
English why haven't we lent into these
relationships sitting on a plate for us
still we just take them for granted no
wonder half of them are pulling away I
think we've dropped the ball though what
do you reckon Lynn well I didn't know
that they were all white and they aren't
surprised
um I'm sorry all the page boys
because we're talking about now for
God's sakes stop the diversity argument
today of all days it's the day before
the coronation is not going to be an
extraordinary event celebrating British
greatness and history in a thousand
years the diversity argument surely can
be silenced just today absolutely what
did we will I look I I think actually
it's an interesting point I wasn't aware
it was going to be quite as you've
depicted let's wait and see tomorrow
actually what we end up seeing I don't
think you can ignore race simply because
Megan and Harry have put race center
stage of their critique about the royal
family and that's made actually I think
a lot of countries in the Commonwealth
that's right particularly in the
Caribbean you see really agitated about
this notion that the royal family are a
bunch of racism well that's absolutely
right and that's exactly why I think we
should stop today discussing it because
it was Megan's agenda and she created it
and I think that is untrue because
anyone has really hard worked hard to
embrace the all the different faiths and
communities in Britain's child I totally
agree it has continuously gone to visit
all sorts of places and the princess
trust has helped so many uh minorities
get on there get on their careers all
the rest of it so it's just totally
unfair untrue will you be watching
absolutely will you be watching yes I
will and even as a Republican and do you
think
any of you
[Laughter]
um great to see you all it's going to be
an amazing day I just think we do with
stuff better than anybody else and well
I'm sure rake over the coals of it next
week but for tomorrow let's just come
together and let's celebrate being
British at our very best so thank you to
my panel